apple is rumored to be preparing a new
iphone rental program that'll be
announced alongside the iphone 14 lineup
this year and that's straight from mark
german one of the most reliable apple
analysts out there yes that means you'll
be able to rent your iphone once a month
directly from apple instead of buying it
outright or through your cell service
provider and yes unfortunately that also
means that you could be paying for years
and never actually pay off an iphone in
full and own it yourself but here's the
kicker a lot of people are gonna do it
and a lot of people are actually gonna
be happy about it including myself but
before i explain the three main reasons
why i'm gonna rent an iphone as well as
thousands of other consumers out there
i've gotta let you know why apple has
finally decided to do it this year well
the main reason according to mark german
is that it's gonna make apple more money
and the reason for that is because those
who will be renting or releasing their
iphones will be getting automatic
upgrades every single year whenever the
latest iphone comes out and that is a
big deal for apple because the average
iphone user upgrades their iphone every
three years or whenever their screen is
cracked or they find the latest iphone
to be enticing enough so for apple this
is going to be a win-win because they
automatically will get a huge number of
pre-orders instantly amounting to the
number of people on this new rental
program mark german also made some
calculations showing how much money
apple could make by leasing iphones at a
monthly rate compared to the outright
cash price with apple making as much as
eighteen hundred dollars off of an
iphone 13 pro max at fifty dollars a
month instead of the regular 10.99 price
not only that but mark mentioned that
apple can also take the old returned
iphones and resell them on the secondary
market to make extra cash so the number
one biggest reason is the fact that
apple can make even more money with this
new rental program and yes i know that
they already have their iphone upgrade
program that i'm actually on right now
but the new rental program will be a lot
different and i'll explain how in just a
minute now moving on to the next reason
why i think apple is finally going to
introduce this rental program this year
it has to do with the general economic
outlook right now as many of us know
inflation has been a hot topic recently
with prices of just about everything
climbing higher and higher each month
gas prices have been climbing food
prices have been going up service prices
have been climbing rent and housing
prices have been climbing in fact home
buyer affordability has dropped to its
lowest level since 2008 the
year-over-year disposable household
income has fallen more than it ever has
in the last 30 years and that is all due
to high inflation making things worse
diesel prices have been skyrocketing
which makes it more expensive for
truckers to transport food and goods and
of course that cost will be passed down
to us the consumers and because of all
of this going on consumer confidence of
the economy is now down to the lowest
level since 2020. apple also recently
reported their first quarter earnings
and mentioned that the supply chain
issues in china are impacting sales and
because of that they could lose between
four to eight billion dollars in sales
in the current quarter and on top of all
of that hashtag recession is now
trending on twitter and the reason for
that is because the us economy shrank in
the first quarter of 2022 which means
that we're now officially 50
of the way there in terms of being in a
recession now i'm not saying that to
scare you guys or say that it's gonna
happen for sure but what i am saying is
that it could lead to less demand for
tech in general including smartphones
and that right there is the third reason
lower consumer demand which apple
analyst and leaker ming chikuo has been
warning about for weeks including
lowered global smartphone demand so what
apple has to do is find a way to make it
easier and less expensive for people to
continue upgrading their iphones because
if we do truly go into a recession
upgrading your iphone is the last thing
that you're going to be worried about
and that is why apple is introducing
this new rental program later this year
at least according to the rumors
especially since rumors are showing that
the iphone lineup is going to be getting
even more expensive because even apple's
margins are getting squeezed so they've
gotta increase their prices but now
let's switch over to the three main
reasons why i think this new rental
program totally makes sense for apple
and why a lot of people are gonna love
it including myself first of all i wanna
mention that i'm already part of apple's
iphone upgrade program and i love it
because i'm planning to upgrade my
iphone every single year because tech is
a high priority in my life in terms of
where i like to spend my money and my
smartphone is the number one piece of
tech that i use the most throughout my
everyday life and on top of that
applecare plus is included so i get the
peace of mind of knowing that i'll be
covered if i do drop my iphone but i
think this new iphone rental deal will
be even better because apple will make
it even less expensive than the current
iphone upgrade program which is going to
attract a lot of customers and the big
reason that i personally think this
makes sense for apple is that they can
potentially bundle this iphone rental
deal with their own apple one services
bundle to get people locked into the
apple ecosystem which means tons of
extra services revenue and for those who
are willing to do this apple will
sweeten the deal by throwing in some
services completely for free because
they know that they'll make that money
up or more over the years because the
customer is locked into the ecosystem so
imagine paying 45 a month for an iphone
13 with icloud apple music apple arcade
and apple tv plus included that is an
absolutely killer deal and that's why i
personally will love renting my iphone
since i already plan to upgrade every
year and yes apple will initially be
losing money by offering some of those
services for free or at a discount but
they'll be locking people into those
services and once they get used to them
they won't want to cancel and the crazy
thing is that even if they're on the
fence about canceling one of those
services they're not gonna want to
because it's part of a bigger bundle
with other services that they really
care about and their iphone rental and
then on the other hand if someone in the
rental program doesn't really care for
the latest iphone because the feature
differences aren't that big well they're
already part of the rental program so
they might as well upgrade anyway which
is obviously great for apple and of
course if things start getting tight for
the consumer because of a potential
recession paying 45 a month for
everything including your iphone and
apple services is an easier pill to
swallow than buying an iphone for 800 or
a thousand dollars outright and that is
exactly why car leases have been getting
so popular over recent years because
they're cheaper month to month than
getting an actual car loan even if it's
not the best or smartest financial
choice in the long run it's still easier
on the consumer month to month right now
it just makes it easier on the
consumer's wallet in the short term
which is why i think apple is going to
be introducing it later this year but
once again don't get me wrong apple is
going to really sweeten the deal and
actually make it worth it for a lot of
people and a pretty dang good deal if
you want apple's other services as well
and apple is willing to take that
initial hit because they're counting on
eventually making that money back and
more through their growing and expanding
services business which by the way has
much better profit margins compared to
apple's hardware business and it's why
apple's been putting so much focus on
services compared to hardware but of
course that is just my opinion so if
you've got some other thoughts on this
topic please let me know down in the
comment section below and if you enjoyed
the video click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you